♪♪
>>> I THINOLDER STATEMENTS
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT VERY, VERY
CAREFULLY.
I THINK THEY MISLED THE SENATE
WITH THE INTENTION OF GETTING
THEIR CONFIRMATION VOTE WITH THE
INTENTION OF OVERRULING ROE.
SO, I'M VERY CONCERNED THAT
THESE JUSTICES HAVE CROSSED A
LINE THAT NO ONE BELIEVED WOULD
BE CROSSED.
>> SENATOR KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
THINKS SEVERAL SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES MISLED THE SENATE ABOUT
THEIR STANCES ON ROE VERSUS WADE
AFTER SAYING THIS AT THEIR
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
>> IS ROE A SUPER PRECEDENT?
>> HOW WOULD YOU DEFINE SUPER
PRECEDENT?
I'M ANSWERING A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT ROE WHICH I THINK
INDICATES THAT ROE DOESN'T FALL
IN THAT CATEGORY.
AND SCHOLARS ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
SAY THAT DOESN'T MEAN ROE SHOULD
BE OVERRULED.
BUT DESCRIPTIVELY, IT MEANS A
CASE THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCEPTED
AND DOESN'T CALL FOR OVERRULING.
>> AS A JUDGE, IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PRECEDENT OF THE SUPREME COURT,
BY IT I MEAN ROE V. WADE AND
PLANNED PARENTHOOD VERSUS CASEY.
IT'S BEEN REAFFIRMED MANY TIMES,
CASEY IS PRECEDENT ON PRECEDENT
WHICH ITSELF IS AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR.
>> A FETUS IS NOT A PERSON FOR
PURPOSES OF THE 14th AMENDMENT.
AND THE BOOK EXPLAINS THAT.
>> DO YOU ACCEPT THAT?
>> THAT'S THE LAW OF THE LAND.
I ACCEPT THE LAW OF THE LAND,
SENATOR, YES.
>> THERE NEEDS TO BE A SPECIAL
JUSTIFICATION FOR OVERRULING THE
PRIOR PRESPRECEDENT.
>> JOINING US NOW JEFFREY TOOBIN
AND JENNIFER RODGERS.
JENNIFER, I GUESS I'M CONFUSED
ABOUT THIS DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
IS SENATOR GILLIBRAND, DO YOU
THINK, TRULY SURPRISED THAT
THESE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
WANT TO OVERTURN PERHAPS ROE V.
WADE?
>> WELL, JOHN, IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE SHE'S SURPRISED SITTING
WATCHING THE CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS FOR YEARS AND WHAT
THEY'LL DO ABOUT IT.
THAT'S THE ISSUE HERE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO WITH
THIS PRECEDENT, OTHER THAN
CONSIDER IT SERIOUSLY AS THE
JUSTICES TO-BE CLAIM.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S ASKING FOR
ANYTHING LIKE INVESTIGATION OR
PERJURY WHICH WOULDN'T GO
ANYWHERE, ANYWAY.
I THINK SHE'S JUST COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THESE
JUSTICES DID MISLEAD PEOPLE IN
THE SENSE THAT -- YOU KNOW, THE
NPR SAYS THAT ROE IS EGREGIOUSLY
WRONG FROM THE START.
THAT SUGGESTS THAT THE JUSTICES
KNEW WHAT THEY KNOW ABOUT ROE
WHICH ISN'T SURPRISING KNOWING
HOW HIGH PROFILE IT IS.
AND AT THE TIME SAYING
CONSIDERING IT AS PRECEDENT AND
WOULDN'T OVERTURN IT TO THAT
EXTENT, SHE'S RIGHT.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THE POLITICAL CONTEXT HERE IS
THAT ROE V. WADE AND ABORTION
RIGHTS IS POPULAR.
AND THE SWING VOTE IN THE
SENATE, ESPECIALLY SUSAN
COLLINS, ARE AT LEAST PUBLICLY
PRO-CHOICE.
SO, THEY NEEDED HER VOTE.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WENT ON HERE
IS THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH IN
PARTICULAR, NEEDS SUSAN COLLINS'
VOTE, SO HE HAD TO APPEAL TO
HER.
AND IF YOU LISTEN TO ALL OF
THOSE QUOTES, IT WAS KAVANAUGH
WHO WAS THE MOST EMPATHICALLY
DEFENDING THE ROE V. WADE
PRECEDENT, IN ORDER TO GET SUSAN
COLLINS' VOTE, WHICH HE DID.
NOW, I THINK MOST OF US WHO WERE
FOLLOWING THE KAVANAUGH
NOMINATION KNEW THAT IT WAS ALL
A LIE.
THAT KAVANAUGH WAS BEING PUT ON
THE COURT TO OVERTURN ROE V.
WADE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT'S HE
WAS DOING.
BUT SOMEHOW, SUSAN COLLINS WAS
CONVINCED BY THIS CHARADE.
AND VOTED TO CONFIRM HIM.
AND NOW WE SEE, APPARENTLY, WHAT
THE RESULTS ARE.
>> JENNIFER, I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WAS SAID BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS BETWEEN JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH AND SENATOR SUSAN
COLLINS.
BUT HIS TESTIMONY RIGHT THERE,
HE DID NOT SAY I WILL NEVER VOTE
TO OVERTURN ROE V. WADE.
HE JUST SAID THAT PRECEDENT IS
IMPORTANT.
AND PRECEDENT UPON PRECEDENT IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
>> RIGHT, WHICH MEANS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
THE IMPRESSION SA DENT OF THE
SUPREME COURT IS THE PRECEDENT
OF THE SUPREME COURT UNTIL IT
DECIDES IT'S NOT.
THEY SAID SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
POINT TO THAT IS ACTUALLY
TECHNICALLY A LIE OR PERJURY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WHAT THEY REALLY DID IS SAY A
WHOLE LOT OF NOTHING WHICH IS
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO TO GET
THROUGH THESE HEARINGS.
>> BERMAN, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
RECOGNIZE, BUT ALL OF THESE
NOMINEES ARE LAWYERS.
AND LAWYERS KNOW HOW TO USE
WORDS IN CAREFUL WAYS SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT EXACTLY LYING.
AND ALL THE WORDS THAT WERE
QUOTED THERE, NO ONE SAID, THAT,
YOU KNOW, I WILL VOTE TO
REAFFIRM ROE V. WADE.
BUT THEY CERTAINLY LEFT THAT
IMPLICATION.
BUT THAT'S ALL THEY DID.
SO THERE WASN'T THEN AN EXPLICIT
LIE.
IT WAS LAWYER TALK.
>> I JUST THINK IT MAY BE A
SITUATION WHERE THERE MAY BE
SENATORS, OR IN THIS CASE, ONE
SENATOR, WHO ALLOWS THEMSELVES
TO BELIEVE SOMETHING.
AND IS THAT ON THE PEOPLE
TESTIFYING?
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW -- WASN'T RUTH
BADER GINSBURG -- I MEAN, WE
HAVEN'T HAD -- THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN OUT-AND-OUT YES AND NO
ANSWERS FOR CONFIRMATIONS IN A
LONG TIME.
>> YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET
THAT, BECAUSE THEY ALL SAY, EVEN
WHEN PRESSED ON WHAT WILL YOU DO
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA?
THEY ALL SAY, WELL, I HAVE TO
KEEP AN OPEN MIND.
I THINK CAN'T PREJUDGE ANYTHING.
IT WILL DEPEND ON THE FACTS OF
THE CASE BEFORE ME.
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET THAT
KIND OF CERTAINTY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY EXPECT
FROM THE PROCESS.
YOU'LL NEVER GET A YES AND NO
ANSWER.
>> IT REALLY GOES BACK TO 1997,
WITH ROBERT BORK, ROBERT BORK
DID ENGAGE WITH SENATORS ABOUT
THE SUBSTANCE OF LAW.
AND TALKED ABOUT HIS OPPOSITION
TO ABORTION RIGHTS IN MUCH MORE
EXPLICIT TERMS THAN ANY
SUBSEQUENT NOMINEE.
AND THEY HAVE ALL TAKEN THE
LESSON TO NOT ANSWER QUESTIONS
AFTER THAT.
IN ANY SORT OF DIRECT WAY.
AND SO, SENATORS NOW HEAR WHAT
THEY WANT TO HEAR.
AND THEY ANSWER THE POLITICAL
CALL THAT THEY FEEL THEY HAVE
TO.
SUSAN COLLINS ANSWERED THE
POLITICAL CALL OF MITCH
McCONNELL, THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
WHO REALLY NEEDED HER VOTE ON
KAVANAUG